this isn't a debate about concrete this
is a debate about the future of our
country whether we are going to stay
right at the heart of the global economy
as we have been for hundreds of years or
whether we are going to allow other
countries to take over that role and we
will increase in increasingly beyond the
branch line to growth but as the globe
changes as the world economy changes and
we see the growth of South American
economies and Asian economies
particularly China we're increasingly
missing out figured as a consumer I mean
I think the problems that we find is
that the airports in generally speaking
but particularly with Heathrow and
Gatwick seem to break down you know
times when you need them you know when
it snows they grind to a halt there are
other times when I have problems because
the capacity is you know the runnings
the Sonia maximum capacity I think I
think it is a mistake in terms of the
terms of reference of the Davis
Commission and the terms of reference
that the politicians have put on this
debate that we are only considering one
additional runway in Britain between now
and 2050 and that's a mistake for so
many reasons but the first one that
comes to mind is at the Chinese in that
time will have built 46 new airports
yeah and we are really blinking
ourselves a little bit to some of the
necessities that UK businesses and
consumers will have as the demand for
air travel continues to grow so we are
going to need more runways